well online and on-campus free speech is
imperiled in the name of tolerance a
majority of college students now say
that protecting diversity is more
important than free speech as if they're
mutually exclusive on Twitter YouTube
and Facebook of course accounts are
routinely banned and opinions suppressed
in the name of fighting hate which is
never precisely defined but you know
what they mean the movement comes mostly
from the left but many traditions some
of them anyway traditional liberals are
upset about it and the Dean strossen is
a former president of the ACLU and she
just released a brand new book called
hate : why we should resist it with free
speech not censorship the in Strassman
joins us tonight
Dean thanks for coming on my pleasure
for a first to confession you're the
kind of liberal I used to make fun of
and now I wish there are more people
like you on the left there seem to be
very few why the change why are you one
of the only people on the left saying
wait hold on free speech is more
important than anything else well I'm
not going to demonize the left Tucker
because I completely agree with the
sentiment expressed by former
journalists I mean sadly he died several
years ago Nat Hentoff whose book title
said it all freedom of speech for me but
not for thee how the left and right
relentlessly censor each other so upon
that hold on hold on Nat Hentoff was a
wonderful man and I wouldn't say toward
the end of his life he was much of a
liberal he was a pro-life activist the
Liberals are defending individual
liberties and that's the most important
value right and I wanted that group
messages of my book is that all of us
regardless of where we fall on the
political spectrum have a crucial stake
in defending the same robust freedom of
speech that the US Supreme Court
interestingly despite its ideological
diversity unanimously supports in the
Supreme Court's most recent decision on
so-called hate speech last summer all of
the justices struck down a federal
statute that prohibited the use of
so-called disparaging or demeaning terms
as trademark to subject to trademark
protection so
they upheld the right interestingly
enough of an Asian American rock band to
choose the name the slants of course
that's a disparaging term but the Simon
Tam and the other Asian American rock
band members chose that not to denigrate
their own ethnic origin but for exactly
the opposite reason to celebrate their
dignity and to empower themselves and
show their pride and that illustrates
Tucker the problem with handing over to
government the power to pick and choose
which particular words are going to be
ruled out of Bounce you have to look at
the context you have to take you know
all of us have different subjective
perceptions and we have to make these
decisions for ourselves and not try
agree to the government I agree we
completely and the reason that that
right really is enshrined in modern laws
because the ACLU in the Brandenburg case
in 1967 and a bunch of other free speech
cases at the ACLU which you ran for
years brought to the to the High Court
but the main threats to speech now exist
not from government but from big
technology companies particularly from
Google and Facebook and Twitter they're
the conduit through which all
information flows they control speech
and they're swelling it and the ACLU is
saying nothing and I don't know why well
let me tell you there is a big legal
problem here in terms of remedies for
what clearly are restrictions on speech
and by the way I disagree with you that
the ACLU has not spoken up but first
most people do not understand that the
First Amendment free speech guarantee
only applies to government to the public
sector so you have no First Amendment
rights with respect to Facebook and the
other private tech companies yes but you
can bring pressure on them and Tucker
the ACLU along with a large coalition of
other civil rights and civil liberties
organizations have been complaining to
Facebook for years about how they are
wielding their power to take down hate
speech we've complained that they have
not done it in a way that is supportive
of equal rights and civil rights
I respectfully disagree with you I think
if eight
see you has stood back now it's spending
its all the time defending illegal
aliens whereas everybody in the world is
so sorry let me tell you that some of us
can defend all fundamental freedoms no
but the emphasis on speech has been
absent with the issue tell that to the
people who are criticizing the ACLU and
lobbying us to change our position which
we have not because we defended the free
speech rights of the alt-right
demonstrators in Charlottesville that is
a decision that I stand by and that my
ACLU colleagues stand by in part no no
that's not true so you college do not
stand by that's - no that's a look I'm
here to tell you how much I respect your
views but you're not being honest there
and discussion within but you know what
we have not seen what we saw during the
Skokie case in the late 1970s that
raised exactly the same issue when the
ACLU came to the defense of a group of
neo-nazis to demonstrate in a town with
a large number of Holocaust survivors
and other Jews no irony then lost 15% of
our members nationwide and that has not
happened now of course there are people
that are arguing that we should not
continue to take those cases but the
leadership has not has not diverted from
that in because you yourself said that
we don't have to choose between
diversity and equality on the one hand
and free speech on the other hand and I
couldn't agree with you more
these are mutually reinforcing and all
of us who care about racial justice and
other equality causes have the biggest
stake in defending robust freedom you
filibustered me and I've let you do it
because I think you're an important
voice for free speech though I do think
that but I think you're wrong on some of
those details but we're gonna have to
talk okay thank you